la guerra en ucrania se siente más cerca
que nunca de los sirios cuando se
cumplen 11 años de este conflicto armado
que con ayuda de la artillería y los
bombardeos rusos han mantenido al
presidente bashar el asad en el poder
los sirios comparten el mismo dolor que
sienten ahora los ucranianos que han
perdido a más de medio millón de seres
queridos han vivido la separación y la
huida de 12 millones de compatriotas que
malviven en los campamentos de
refugiados en los países vecinos y
también en europa a siria le preocupa el
futuro de ucrania porque tendrá
consecuencias directas en el país
estamos hablando de que siria sufre una
de las mayores crisis humanitarias del
mundo y las presiones y las sanciones
internacionales podrían llevar a rusia a
utilizar su derecho a veto en el consejo
de seguridad de la onu y cerrar los
corredores humanitarios
dejando a millones de sirios a su suerte
en un país devastado por la guerra
siria es también cantera de yihadistas
pero también de mercenarios entrenados
por rusia que podrían
servir a los rusos en la guerra nuclear
ya si se sigue alargando es por eso que
hoy se ha visto en los pocos bastiones
rebeldes que todavía quedan en siria en
la provincia de idlib empuñar la bandera
verde blanca y negra de la revolución
siria pero también la bandera azul y
amarilla de ucrania en solidaridad